onde essa coisa das multidões não é
mesmo verdade né não
o bom é muito bom dia com muito gosto
que estou aqui neste palco pela terceira
vez o que é assim um privilégio é eu fui
colega dani na escola e tentar e depois
dela ter feito a apresentação com o
explorador eu trouxe aqui os meus
pequenos provedores
só uma marca da madeira e digamos que a
forma de partilhar convosco o amor que
tenho por essa terra vai falar do mar
que são aqueles diálogos de luiza
marketing que é que acha que é supérfluo
e isso é importante para nós enquanto
pessoas para os nossos territórios para
o nosso país em particular para dar a
todos vocês já viram certamente um
cãozinho fazer xixi talvez aquela
questão que eu dizia deixa andar muito
depressa
toda a gente sabe um cãozinho fazer xixi
na mala de um carro certo é que eu sei
fazer avançar a sua marca e fazer uma
marca é isso é definir um território
o mundo está a mexer todos os dias o
mundo está a mudar
por isso deixamos a nossa marca
precisamos estar sempre a fazer xixi
o mundo está pela primeira vez conectado
existe uma democracia plantar e estamos
todos ligados temos amigos em todas as
partes do mundo ainda ainda só deste
modo realmente ainda não dê de outro de
outro planeta o que significa que
estamos aqui eles podem estar a ser
propagado além das nossas fronteiras
físicas
isso tudo numa das minhas teorias dizer
usando esta imagem gosto muito que é que
o que está ali não é que o que está ali
ou seja o que nós dizemos ou seja mais
de metade daquilo que diz sobre nós
sobre as marcas sobre o que fazemos não
é da nossa responsabilidade
são pessoas que não consente que dizem
bem ou mal nós por isso fazer uma marca
é mais ou menos controlar o estado acha
que não é quem
quem está um pouco fora destas coisas
veja o que aconteceu aí united um
passageiro no interior teve um problema
o mundo estava a olhar pra aquele
interior foi posto um telemóvel a
empresa não tomou conta do assunto
embrulhos e que tem um bilhão de dólares
no mesmo dia não voltou
a fundación crash da bolsa e não voltou
a atuar na empresa exatamente a mesma
com a mesma opressão mas o que é certo é
que teve um efeito econômico
extraordinário então que que é isso
final de uma marca padre antónio vieira
já foi citado aqui hoje num ano paulo de
uma coisa muito básica que é colocarmos
um produto onde o facto tem mais a
valorização
gosto desta desta idéia toda a gente
sabe que usa portuguesa é extraordinário
pois os espanhóis também também acham
isso vai em portugal comprar azeite
português pra colocar no mercado
internacional com rótulos italianos 1
litro de azeite extraordinário português
com rock em português ou dois euros um
lixo extraordinário um litro de leite
extraordinário português com rock
espanhol 14 euros
um litro de açaí extraordinário
português com rótulo italiano paulo 8
euros
a qualidade intrínseca das coisas não é
suficiente por muito que isso nos custos
mas neste caso e muitos outros casos é
qualidade de vida é ter um mesmo tarde o
valor do do produto que significa que
nós temos que trabalhar na percepção
daquilo que os outros acham das nossas
coisas não sendo suficiente que o que
fazemos
gosto muito de explicar o que é uma
marca várias formas e um dos melhores
exemplos um dos que eu gosto mais a
estes saltos altos
aparentemente uma coisa sem nexo porque
senão nós temos uma análise fria no
mercado dizemos que o chelsea não tem
qualquer outro lado
imagine que alguém vem aqui do outro
planeta e vai fazer um teste no mercado
pra vestir calçar senhoras num piso
irregular de um país ainda por cima da
calçada portuguesa não tem ex certo
no entanto uma rapariga o senhor tem
alguma possibilidade de em média 25
participantes autos todos os
absolutamente funcionais muito mais o
jogador já atuou pela baixa estou sempre
em baixo é sempre um pé para não abrir
aqui na bahia que grandes polêmicas
gosto muito deste exemplo porque os
saltos altos enquadram aquilo que pra
mim são as quatros funcionalidades das
marcas
nossas finalidades estéticas as
funcionalidades emocionais mas
funcionários sociais sociais e
naturalmente as funcionalidades
funcionais puxar os autos permitem andar
mais ou menos não é uma mulher consegue
sentir melhor consigo a conseguir
própria melhor com os outros certo mas
acrescentou que o equipamento aqui uma
superficialidade explique um pouco
melhor este salto alto aqui tem um
particular sentido aqui mas era essa tal
falta acrescentar todas as
funcionalidades de uma marca podem levar
a que essa marca seja melhor do mundo
quando nós é quando nós acrescentamos
essas dimensões até um caixão quais são
as dimensões uma dimensão física de um
produto objetiva e concreta um produto
tem que ser colocado com o melhor preço
melhor mercado não for mais valorizado
mas com estética certa um x de juízo
estético professores dão notas melhores
alunos mais atraentes
a juíza da 1 penas menores é criminosos
mais atrativos mais atraentes nós somos
cheios de vícios técnico ética não é uma
coisa das minas no sentido de que a soja
é alguma coisa nós temos que ter um
posicionamento técnico a nossa coisa
como é que nós queremos que ela seja
pressionada no dia em que a estética é
no fundo a primeira valorização que nós
fazemos as coisas pois em termos de nome
lá atrás no meu entender o grande erro
do século passado disse que o homem é um
ser racional
como é que é possível como é que é
possível quando nós pensamos conquistou
nos borramos do medo certo
não não estamos nervosos no excel ou
seja transformamos ninguém daqui desta
sala toma nenhuma em uma decisão
importante de sua vida baseada na
racionalidade
que eu saiba a imagem de uma mulher para
casar faça uma folha de cálculo
desaprovamos capazes de investir mais e
melhor o outro não sei qual ele faz ou
não faz um cálculo vai ser um grande
amor certamente porque não há porque não
tem não tem sentido
então nós escolhemos quem vive conosco
tomamos as decisões mais importantes da
nossa vida
com base no cap link pequenos negócios
insistimos dos poderes campo porque os
negócios não eu ontem
o racional está algures aqui nesta que
dizia não não eu sou racional certo
nacional pessoa economista não é lado
foi o espírito como você quer do mar têm
acesso ao longo do jantar foi se
libertando mais liberdade e ela beber um
pouquinho e depois libertado israel faça
isso e sinto isto e sinto aqui um
exemplo que sabia que era só que eu só
quero só nó a matemática humana não é
não é só um engano que nós mais uma vez
relacionamos prisões e nessa medida que
temos que tratar as coisas do ponto de
vista do ponto vista social esperando um
contato muito importante nós chamávamos
é escolhido durante chamávamos o cuidado
de madre teresa de calcutá é porque era
muito importante mas não era sexy e
portanto já há até mesmo a terra em
pouco tempo isso não era e não é
considerado hoje em dia nós não combinam
com não consideramos comprar uma marca
que não tenha uma nós votamos com
carteira no sentido compramos uma marca
ou outra o que significa que nós nós
queremos saber o que essa marca vai
trazendo bem pra convidava vai trazer
bem para o mundo que vai terceiro que
vai trazer vai não apenas uma máquina de
fazer né
os produtos são marcas os serviços são
marcas as pessoas são marcas
as cidades são marcas dos países são
marcas mas gastar em marcas e os
criminosos e hoje e os gestores têm
marca não só que este exemplo aqui com
uma com nenhum prazer apenas para dizer
que explorou crescer a apal do turismo e
porque precisa de financiamento e
precisa de angariar pessoas que se batem
pela sua causa e tem conseguido reparar
que às vezes faz tudo com uma grande
fotografia marca infelizmente tem
conseguido também com essas regiões são
ou não um país uma marca incrível é que
é um território marca uma vez que
estamos a falar da madeira da amazônia
genial é ter uma questão de identidade
em primeiro lugar não é uma questão de
dodô nacionalismo
mas é uma questão do impacto que têm na
economia ou seja eu não posso dizer eu
tenho um país
o fantástico e pobre não esqueçamos que
30% do nosso país é pobre e portanto
todo o exagero que nós possamos fazer da
nossa tudo que nós precisamos retirar
nossa história da nossa geografia da
nossa cultura para encontrar a nossa
economia é uma obrigação que temos que
fazer e portanto não é um nacionalismo
chapa mas fazer uma marca não é um ponto
de chegada um caminho um caminho que
mora tempo paciência e resiliência que
no caso da madeira com só seis anos no
marca de estrelas profunda que todos
passaram os que os conflitos tensão ou
seja todos os fatores todos e todos
aqueles que são os fatores de
diferenciação
desde o território de muitos outros 17
ano passado a chance que não tem futuro
e muitas vezes procuram o futuro
retaliando o passado a chance que a
modernidade tem que ser alguma coisa de
novo eu não acredito
a modalidade não pode ser entendido do
passat também para quem não têm soja
portugal é um dos países do mundo mais
passado tem para dar um futuro e
portanto seria completamente e realista
nós não estamos fora uma herança que nos
foi oferecida mas a tradição não é
apenas a continuidade do tempo que está
em pode ter muitos anos disse não ter
não ter valor é quanto tempo é o que nós
somos nesse tempo é como é que nós nos
damos com nesse nesse tempo e energia
colocamos na nossa marca esta marca
neste oval do funchal do funcho e talvez
inspirada no título um teu como go com
funcho fogo aos deuses como forma de
provar a audácia pelo pelo conhecimento
e pela partilha de conhecimento humano
esta que um jardim da natureza onde um
som as brisas dos táxis 11 linhas ea
discutir a questão
são são as vespas nem precisei da ilha
virilha eu sempre coloco um lado israel
nós não temos aqui nada está tudo muito
fraquinho e vamos andando assim as
coisas que são portuguesas e brasileiras
ainda se acham mais pois depois os
madeirenses são as duas marcas
o avaí foi feito pelo madeirense aquela
que é grande o grande símbolo do hawai
que a colocação das flores prefeito
emigrantes madeirenses que tiveram que
sair e que deverão criar marcas um ciclo
de ouvir essas marcas marcas
identitárias que hoje tem imensa
floresta que é uma marca abordada
ambições que marcou gols no adversário o
destino de uma natureza diversa como
também aqui hoje já foi já foi citado
pela al da cdu em cidades de de sair
preto na área
o sítio melhor onde a indústria do
turismo é só um é o maior exemplo do
país estamos a falar de turismo com com
207 estamos a falar muito mas quero
falar de uma base desse turismo tendo
tem 20 milhões
floresta laurissilva que saíra continua
viva pra lá em todos os dias onde
estiveram dinossauros mas pelo menos foi
dessa dessa altura nos encontramos um
dos temas mais extraordinários da regra
que abraça é a ilha em espirais até ao
mar e que hoje está a ser usada como
engraçado porque teoricamente um
patrimônio que era funcional em que já
não tem tanta funcionalidade ou estás
exportados ou seja 11 um recurso
endógeno que não é de utilizar o véu nem
nem neném está se está a ser disputado
porque a maioria das pessoas que
consomem são estrangeiros certo e que
foi usada a tecnologia podemos levar
isso mais longe então seremos capazes
ainda de disputar mais é que temos uma
natureza que ambos do sublime
extraordinário para vocês canadá e são
daqui
karzai normal antes pacto temos uma
coisa extraordinária vanilse cima e
material que a imaginação contraturado
furar a obrigação de transformar em
material de nos calarmos de conseguirmos
falar de de começarmos a estar na rota
das estrelas de outras estrelas
eu acredito muito que portugal tem
muitas condições conquistaram muito pelo
estômago
nós temos temos essa temos em termos
essa riqueza e aqui na madeira é com com
bastante importância uma energia que
transforma o velho novo o turismo um
colega o turismo ao empreendorismo neste
caso com o projeto das levadas onde um
dedal em onde temos o candidato em abril
certamente a história do candidato em
uma espécie de quais no porto do porto
santo que é o responsável pela pela não
existência de grande grande grande
infestação era uma coisa que ficou para
a história é uma coisa que ela achava
que ela estava grávida depois conseguiu
produzir e fazer uma espécie de darem
uma terra que tem como tem como
propósito ou tem como desafio de
equilibrar o charme
521 pessoas da menina tem 50 e 70 anos e
as ons
outra vez os ajustes no texto
na verdade são jovens mas que é possível
ligar essas duas
essas duas gerações uma marca não é uma
marca o marketing não é uma coisa
superficial é uma coisa essencial é um
regador ensinado mandam uma região um
fator de desenvolvimento econômico
uma é preciso uma pra dar uma marca que
organiza a sua tradição do grande rio de
petrolina quando ela conhece mal
já nos estados unidos aqui brindado com
um convite do porto o senhor trama está
a fazer vencer aquela história aquela
história extraordinária é muito cuidado
com o que fazem é modernizado tendem a
economizar e todos aqui um exemplo
shukarno desculpa e só come que funciona
assim um exemplo pra mim scut que quando
os golpistas é que aqui nessa sala
nenhum nenhum nova contra o fã nenhum
uma coisa completamente desalinhada da
nossa identidade pois somos um destino
número um que o gol e colisão os
territórios igualzinho e certamente
muitos muitos e não há cama muito valor
unitário mas cavalo reilly triunfo o
melhor do mundo
um turista de quest gasta três vezes
mais conquista está alinhado com a nossa
história a nossa cultura das pessoas que
eu conheço que a opção neste negócio
estão muito insatisfeitas
acho que temos que pensar o que podemos
fazer para o futuro portugal parece que
se esqueceu de identidade como se nunca
tivesse nós fomos os pioneiros
estes dias foram à lua aqui que eu acho
que os levam a quem é que acham foram
materiais que o homem que entre outros
que provou que o que o mundo que o mundo
era um arquipélago
nós somos descendentes desses homens
lembrem se que a menina fazer xixi
onde está a mudar o que significa que
está nos bairros não significa que vou
estar bem amanhã caso contrário é válido
ou seja está nas nossas mãos e capaz de
alterar o nosso destino é possível é
concreto e e uma obrigação
estava a querer resolver isso não fui
não fui ontem num e foi mesmo o prêmio
futuro vai ser passado não fique no
passado vai ser passado pela forma como
quando nós conseguimos nós somos aqui os
que estamos à espera
está nas nossas mãos fazer fazer essa
mudança temos que buscar nossa site nas
coisas extraordinárias e por isso
molduras douradas hoje que é preciso que
vivemos num mundo onde a pressão é tão
importante como rico como realidade é
preciso fazer explodir a energia
criativa da medalha um passado que eles
querem
o futuro das marcas sons do homem do
petróleo na economia porque não dizer
todos os dias e talvez alguns de vocês
possam ter um livro esta sexta
este conto das mil e uma noites onde era
o cinto na forma simples a história de
blu ray que todas as noites dormindo
como eu perguntava se era por falta de
espaço os termos top que é certo é que
eu estava até por sua vez da serasa que
era linda de morrer e que não queria
morrer até contou com o show contará o
raio história muito toda que não
terminava e continuava sempre no dia sim
uma história muito sedutora que não
terminava continuava sempre no dia
seguinte uma história muito torá que não
terminava continuava sempre um dia assim
foi é fazer uma marca é isso é todos os
dias contados mas para muitos tutora que
não termine e continua sempre podia sim
olhar fazer uma marca é gerir uma
situação é assim que nós precisamos de
fazer qualquer que façamos conosco que
façam conosco que fazemos aos outros e
quando se e no princípio do século
passado um homem senhor os futuros
reforços no com o carro eo mundo inteiro
comprou eu fiz uma empresa
extraordinária nos instantes que se eu
sonhar que por ser o senhor que cria uma
marca que chama eterna pois o mundo a
sonhar ea empresa pequenina sem ninguém
acreditar mas com o mundo acreditar
ultrapassou a capitalização bolsista da
forma ou seja nove emissões não vivemos
realizados é realidade pouco importa
estamos a falar de mim é concreto o
mundo está disposto a pagar mais um
sonho do reinado
nós temos um sonho do nosso poeta temos
uma mensagem para cumprir
temos que estar alinhados com o que nós
somos como a nossa alma
nós somos enquanto enquanto enquanto
povo
o tio uma guerra e que eu passava aqui
uns tempos dizia foi um ministro da
economia ou perdeu e e esse senhor
primeiro-ministro temos que acabar com o
orçamento da cultura vai ficar sem
cultura profic para que vamos ganhar a
guerra mas é isso mesmo que temos que
pensar
as marcas não podem ser não podem ter um
drive na economia não é sua principal
o principal motivo que podemos a poesia
para que o cheiro economia muito cuidado
com o superficial muito cuidado quando
estiverem é a pensar em decisões
racionais pessoa com sintoma
pensei que o ps é essencial para esse
perco não é
as marcas foram maltratados mãe muito
cedo se forem bem tratados podem viver
para sempre
obrigado e mangueira
[Aplausos]